so you guys know that over the past week
or so we've been collecting your
favorite holiday recipes but this week
we're also sharing some of our own so
I'm sharing my recipe for what are
called buttermilk Dill cashews so those
are three words you probably normally
wouldn't think about together but the
the idea here is you've got your raw
cashews and for any kind of nut that has
coating on it the secret is egg white
so you put the egg white in a cup or
some kind of a container and you whisk
it up into a little bit of a froth and
then you add your powdered ingredients
which in this case some common stuff
garlic powder onion powder coriander
lime juice dill weed for sure and dry
mustard then you pour that into the
coffee cup and that's what you pour onto
the nuts and you mix them up
like that and then you pour them on a a
cookie pan with your spring okay okay
and that keeps them from what from
sticking or burning or what no that's
all the uh the spray absolutely because
you're going to have the oven up at like
325. okay for about 10 minutes at a time
you want to make sure you stir them
because you don't want the nuts to burn
okay
um but the idea is to make them crunchy
and I have samples for you guys here
these are the can we show them what they
look like absolutely and I'm going to
show you what these look like those are
really now I don't know if buttermilk
powder has gluten in it I don't think it
does okay so go ahead anyway we're gonna
we're gonna just dive in it's crunchy
wow it's got a little tank oh because
you're adding citric acid powder which
looks kind of weird but it is available
at Sprouts citric acid powder and
buttermilk powder powder so we have the
recipe up on our website and we want
your recipe in the online Good Day Las
Vegas holiday recipe cookbook send it to
Pitts p-i-x at
oh my gosh 8newsnow.com these are really
good so Nate I have a question just
right quick yeah what is it that I'm
getting right here can we come back to
us on camera right quick right here Tang
it's the citric acid is that what it is
and the dill it's good though but it's
almost like yeah it's Tangy explosion of
flavor that you'd never get from a wow
cashew exactly I love it don't let me
mirror bowl that big I need the whole
recipe is online so check it out yeah
that's our good day cookbook and so
you're cooking something tomorrow uh
Wednesday oh Wednesday okay tomorrow oh
okay